it's like also side notes if i ever do
meet you in real life and you're like an
online personality
that i might not know please introduce
yourself as like your internet handle
i've had so many times you're like you
you someone introduces them to you and
they're just like
oh yeah i'm i'm like matt or something
yeah and it's just like
okay do i do i know that too they're
like do you remember me and i'm like who
and they're like oh i'm like
ex-girl with this avatar like yeah and
which one of the 70 are you i know right
so yeah oh
should i go back on top okay no just
like yeah just introduce yourself by
your internet handle just
just just like messing so much i feel
like i i
get it because it's weird like i i feel
weird being like yeah hi
i'm gigguk you know what i mean like i
get i just say hi i'm connor c dog
online
yeah that's what i said yeah just just
like introduce yourself with that's
in mind so we we know because we don't
nowadays people know each other by their
their internet
yeah a lot of the times more people know
you forgive than gone right probably
yeah yeah
yeah that's because i mean that's how it
is right i mean that's that's fine by me
because like
giga i don't know how you guys got your
names but i mean i
i don't know the origin story with the
anime man i don't know how the [ __ ] you
thought
it was like a family nickname that my
dad thought up when i was born
so like i'm just i'm just used to it
like if someone calls me gigg or gant
like my family to this day still call me
gig so like i'm i'm used to hearing that
so
i'm completely comfortable with just
people calling me giggup
if my parents call me anime man i would
think i was like disowned or something
if you call me the anime zone on the
other hand but now we got a problem now
we've got a [ __ ] problem
i do that sometimes just to [ __ ] with
god
we like to joke around on this podcast
yeah i know it's just yeah that's the
one thing i guess i
it's really weird right because i've
never
been used to introducing myself as like
hi i'm the anime man because
before all of this it was just so
natural for me and i'm sure it is for
with a lot of people
to just be like hi i'm joey yeah because
i just want you to get to know me as a
person but
it's weird now how it's gotten to that
point where
if you just say hi i'm joey yeah or some
people just like
[ __ ] that who do i do i know you i know
which one
joey yeah are you even verified bro
if not don't talk to me yeah it's scary
man like numbers on the internet man
yeah scary [ __ ] it really
it really scarily changes the perception
of how you see someone even if you don't
mean it that way yeah you touched on
that roughly on episode one right
yeah how we met each other and how the
numbers played and factor
yeah going back to what i'm saying
earlier with the uh
how i felt like i was always on the
outskirts of the community i think that
experience that i did have
very much solidified to me like i'm okay
with not making friends
like i'm gonna keep to myself